♪ (ETHEREAL MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Clear your mind.
Let yourself fall away.
(BREATHING DEEPLY)
And when you fall away,
you gotta trust
that somebody gon' catch you.
You know how you go to
those seminars
where you fall the fuck away,
and they catch your ass?
Eight, nine people catch
your ass.
You trust them motherfuckers
not to drop you.
But you don't know
these motherfuckers.
You don't know them.
You don't know
if these motherfuckers
got weak-ass hands
they gon' drop you on your
motherfuckin' head.
And then you gon' be
in a fuckin' emergency room
and shit.
Riding around in a fuckin'
ambulance,
you know, "What the fuck
happened?"
These motherfuckers dropped me.
(WHISPERS)
They fuckin' dropped me.
Or you can trust me.
Fall away.
Breathe in (INHALES).
Breathe out (EXHALES).
Center yourself.
Try to get centered.
(WHISPERS) Center yourself.
Center yourself.
Keep breathing.
In through your nose,
out through your ass.
You keep doing that.
I'm gonna go and grab me
a fuckin' snack.
I'm in a tapioca mood today.
You know tapioca, your grandma
makes that shit for you.
Fuckin' tapioca.
See? I just took you somewhere.
Now your fuckin' mouth is
watering.
For some fuckin' tapioca.
Now who doesn't like tapioca?
(LAUGHS)
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪